last summer I got a call from a woman
named Ellie and she had heard about the
family separations at the southern
border and wanted to know what she could
do to help she told me the story of her
grandfather and his father when they
were kids in Poland their father fearing
for his son's safety gave them a little
bit of money and told them to walk West
to just keep walking west across Europe
and they did they walked all the way
west across Europe and they got on a
boat and they got to America Ellie said
that when she heard the stories of the
teens walking up across Mexico all she
could think about was her grandfather
and his brother she said that for her
the stories were exactly the same those
brothers were the Hassenfeld brothers
the Haas Bros the Hasbro toy company
which of course brought us mr. Potato
Head but but that is not actually why
I'm telling you this story I'm telling
you this story because it made me think
about whether I would have the faith the
courage to send my teens and I have
three of them on a journey like that
knowing that they wouldn't be safe where
we were would I be able to watch them go
I started my career decades ago at the
southern US border working with Central
American asylum seekers and in the last
16 years I've been at highest the Jewish
organization that fights for refugee
rights around the world as a lawyer and
an advocate and one thing I've learned
is that sometimes the things that we're
told make us safer and stronger actually
don't and in fact some of these policies
have the opposite of the intended
results and in the meantime caused
tremendous and unnecessary suffering so
why are people showing up at our
southern boy
most of the immigrants and refugees that
are coming to our southern border are
fleeing three countries wot Amala
Honduras and El Salvador these countries
are consistently ranked among among the
most violent countries in the world it's
very difficult to be safe in these
countries let alone build a future for
yourself and your family and violence
against women and girls is pervasive
people have been fleeing Central America
for generations generations of refugees
have been coming to our shores fleeing
the nineteen eighty the night the civil
wars of the 1980s in which the United
States was deeply involved this is
nothing new what's new is that recently
there's been a spike in families
children and families showing up a
checkpoints and presenting themselves to
seek asylum now this has been in the
news lately so I want you to remember a
few things as you see those images one
this is not a historically high level of
of interceptions at the southern border
and in fact people are presenting
themselves at checkpoints to people are
showing up with the clothes on their
backs some of them are literally in
flip-flops and three were the most
powerful country in the world it's not a
time to panic it's easy from the safety
of the destination country to think in
terms of absolutes is it legal or is it
illegal but the people who are wrestling
with these questions and making these
decisions about their families are
thinking about very different questions
how do I keep my daughter safe how do I
protect my son
and if you want absolutes
it's absolutely legal to seek asylum
it is a fundamental right in our own
laws and in international law and in
fact
[Music]
it stems from the 1951 Refugee
Convention which was the world's
response to the Holocaust and a way for
countries to say never again would we
return people to countries where they
would be harmed or killed there are
several ways refugees come to this
country one is through the u.s. refugee
admissions program and through that
program the u.s. identifies and selects
refugees abroad and brings them to the
United States last year the u.s.
resettled fewer refugees than at any
time since the program began in 1980 and
this year it will probably be less and
this is at a time when we have more
refugees in the world than at any other
time in recorded history even since
World War two another way that refugees
come to this country is by seeking
asylum asylum seekers are people who
present themselves at a border and say
that they'll be persecuted if they're
sent back home an asylum seeker is
simply somebody who's going through the
process in the United States to prove
that they meet the refugee definition
and it's never been more difficult to
seek asylum border guards are telling
people when they show up at our borders
that our country's full that they simply
can't apply this is unprecedented and
illegal in under a new program with the
kind of Orwellian title migrant
protection protocols refugees are told
they have to wait in Mexico while their
cases make their way through the courts
in the United States and this can take
months or years meanwhile they're not
safe and they have no access to lawyers
our country our government has detained
over 3,000 children separating them from
their parents arms as a deterrent from
seeking asylum many were toddlers and at
least one was a six-year-old blind girl
and this is still going on we spend
billions to detain people in what are
virtually prisons who have committed no
crime and family separation has become
the hallmark of our immigration system
that's a far cry from a shining
city on a hill or a beacon of hope or
all of the other ways we like to talk
about ourselves and our values migration
has always been with us and it always
will be the reasons why people flee
persecution war violence climate change
and the ability now to see on your phone
what life is like in other places those
pressures are only growing but but there
are ways that we can have policies that
reflect our values and actually make
sense given the reality in the world the
first thing we need to do is dial back
the toxic rhetoric that has been the the
basis of our national debate on this
issue for too long
I am NOT an immigrant or refugee myself
but I take these attacks personally
because my grandparents were my
great-grandmother Rose didn't see her
kids for seven years as she tried to
bring them from Poland to New York she
left my grandfather when he was seven it
didn't see him again until he was 14 on
the other side of my family my
grandmother Alisa left Poland in the
1930s and left for what was then the
British Mandate of Palestine and she
never saw her family and friends again
global cooperation as a response to
global migration and displacement would
go a long way towards making migration
something that isn't a crisis but
something that just is then that we deal
with as a global community humanitarian
aid is also critical the amount of
support we provide to countries in
Central America that are sending
refugees and migrants is a tiny fraction
of the amount we spend on enforcement
and detention and we can absolutely have
an asylum system that works for a tiny
fraction of the cost of a wall we could
hire more judges make sure asylum
seekers have lawyers and commit to a
humane Asylum system
and we could resettle more refugees to
give you a sense of the decline in the
refugee program three years ago the u.s.
resettled fifteen thousand Syrian
refugees in response to the largest
refugee crisis on earth a year later
that number was three thousand and last
year that number was 62 people 62 people
despite the harsh rhetoric and efforts
to block immigration keep refugees out
of the country support for Refugees and
immigrants in this country according to
polls has never been higher
organizations like Hayase where I work
and other humanitarian and faith-based
organizations make it easy for you to
take a stand when there's a law that's
worth opposing or a law that's worth
supporting or policy that needs
oversight if you have a phone you can do
something and if you want to do more you
can I will tell you that if you see one
of these detention centers along the
border with children in them their their
jails you will never be the same what I
loved so much about my call with Ellie
was that she knew in her core that the
stories of her grandparents were no
different than today's stories and she
wanted to do something about it if I
leave you with one thing beyond the back
story for mr. Potatohead which is of
course a good good story to leave with
it's not a country shows strength
through compassion and pragmatism not
through force and through fear
these stories of the Hassenfeld and my
relatives and your relatives are still
happening today they're all the same a
country is strong when it says to the
refugee not go away but it's okay we've
got you you're safe
thank you
[Applause]